we played this yesterday we had some fun
at the expense of mark Dondero he's a
sports anchor reporter WPRI channel 12
in Providence now let's let's play this
again then we'll bring in Mark who's
kind enough to join us and have some fun
with this and I tell people in this
business there's no more humbling
situation than when you're in a press
conference and you ask a question and
all of a sudden that coach decides that
he does not want to play here you go
coach the game is played predominantly
in the teens is that a game style that
you're comfortable playing not scoring a
lot of points not high-flying offense
necessarily more low-scoring
grind-it-out is that a style you like
the team prefers prefer to win
mark Dondero joins us now mark how did
you feel after the first question got
rejected matumbo right back in your face
hey Dan thanks very much for having me
well I was disappointed because I had it
scripted perfectly and I thought I
executed it perfectly in my head then
when he threw it back at me I had to
kind of reword things I didn't want to
use the word prefer it just sort of came
out and bodyslams big time you decided
to follow back up to clarifying and then
all of a sudden you're in no-man's land
what's that feeling like I mean I tried
to find a different way to word the
question I thought the way I asked it
the first time would be understood so he
got me he made me he kind of maneuvered
me into a corner to ask it the way he
wanted it answered and then I gave him
an out so I paid the price
have you asked questions before to
Belichick I have asked bill probably a
hundred questions and what really I want
they bother me but it kind of just
befuddled me I've asked him I think more
explosive questions more not
controversial but questions I thought
may elicit that type of response in the
past that didn't he either enjoyed or
answered and it was fine that time I'm
thinking I'm asking some question about
the defense in playing a grinded out
style game nothing inflammatory and I
get crushed I was surprised I let those
things happen what did the rest of the
media then they may say anything to you
afterwards I was getting more looks and
you know just I hope you can pick
yourself up after that that was a
situation that nobody that I can I can
say that's in that room and a regular
basis ever wants to be in it and it does
happen sometimes
I got crushed on Twitter pretty hard
yeah you asked the question you hung in
there you know the part of the problem
and I say this to people who want to do
this for a living ask an open-ended
question you know so I think he got
caught with a closed-ended question that
you give him an out where he can give
you a one-word answer and I just I
always want to get Belichick to talk
he's never been on this show and I know
how difficult that is he either respect
you or
doesn't he'll either engage or he won't
but I think asking an open-ended
question just to get him to talk about
his offense or his defense is probably
the the best way to go about him but man
I I don't envy anybody who goes in
that's into that press conference with
him because it's intimidating and you
know if I could stand my cents I've
gotten to Providence my philosophy and
strategy has been and I don't need to
tell you this obviously but when you're
asking questions and interviewing
somebody you know it's about the person
being interviewed it's about the answer
that they give well I went quickly that
he's not going to give a lot of answers
you know how he is you know so I decided
for the sake of a story and making good
TV because I'm a reporter TV reporter it
has to become about the question so I
focus with Belichick what I say in the
question and almost make the question
what's the entertaining part and then
whatever he answers with he answers with
I think I've done all right doing that
for the sake of my stories that I have
to do every Wednesday when I go that's
my philosophy he's not going to answer
it all right well we'll use certain
words and certain phrasing and make it
about the question that's that's how I
do it he's marked Dondero he's a sports
anchor reporter WPRI channel 12 in
Providence all right I'm gonna give you
the first question for Wednesday's press
conference with Bill Belichick what are
you asking the first question will be
why did you decide to trade Jimmy
Garoppolo the answer will be we did what
was best for the football team and we'll
get that answer I'm assuming all day
long one question I might ask her or
wouldn't mind knowing I don't know if
he'd go there does you know there's a
million questions does Tom Brady's
commitment to health and the book and
all the nutritional things did that play
a role in this I mean this is a 40 year
old quarterback that he seems to be
committing to a long term to me this
goes against everything that he has done
in the past I can't think of it and you
know what this is the guy who everybody
thought was the future yeah at the
position I'm stunned that this happened
I'm stunned that they traded him you're
you guys are talking about timing and
what they cup I'm just stunned that he
got traded well I think they got back to
into a corner they lost leverage you got
Don you represents Brady and
blow I think they realized the defense
wasn't as good it was as it was going to
be and if you're going to go to they're
not winning the Superbowl with Tom Brady
this year in my opinion now you have to
have some help on that defensive line
and I think they used that second-round
pick today and try to get some help
today they need help now this is a team
that was built to win now back-to-back
Super Bowls what do you think they do
I'm with you here's what I think that
they should have done before I think
they should have traded him before
because you have Tom Brady now we didn't
know what this season was going to
become the defense hasn't been nearly as
good as people thought what what I would
have done is traded Jimmy Garoppolo
tried to get as much as you can for him
to help Tom Brady to ride with Tom Brady
even though he doesn't have a lot of
time left because I just think you know
what you have Brady can win Super Bowls
he's proven that Jimmy G maybe he's a
great quarterback of Pro Bowl
quarterback but if he's flippers or Tony
Romo who are great quarterbacks you know
down the road they can't if they can't
get you to a Super Bowl or win a Super
Bowl it's nice to be good and in
contention but I would personally rather
win Super Bowls
now with Tom Brady because we know he
can help him as much as possible and
then later we'll figure it out that's
what I would have done I'm glad they
committed one way or another
second-round pick you know Sam Bradford
good evening we went for a first-round
pick I I think he's an average
quarterback an injury prone quarterback
so that you can look at that and say I
don't know about the second-round pick I
would win now with Brady keep fighting
the good fight mark hey thanks for
having me on our debt I appreciate all
right mark Dondero the sports anchor
reporter WPRI channel 12 and Providence
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]